[Music]
news to me pink carpet news everyone
it's Kristin Gill here at beautycon at
2018 where we just spoke with Jonathan
van add some queer eye condition on how
he's going to be involved in Cabrales
big day Jonathan keeps telling me I said
do you want to be my best man he's like
no I want to be your ring bearer there
your little ring girl and I'm like okay
girl Kurama told us that you are going
to be a ring bearer possibly I knew to
me pink carpet news I'm so excited I
would be so honored to be a ring bearer
I just want to wear like a really cute
little like Prince Charles out there
like I wear like a little like a white
like a little like frog
we're sure Jonathan meant Prince Louis
not the newborns grandfather but we get
the excitement over recreating the cute
look oh did you see the christening gown
and I look I have this day Princess Kate
like gets recycling fashion thank you
for giving me permission to recycle
things like no it's a kid give me like a
family thing like all three of those
babies or the synchrony gun is so
stunning I want a 31 year old six foot
tall version of that christening gown I
need 100 stunning and a bachelor party
Bobby planning well I'm not the best at
planning things um I will be there I
hope it's turquoise water no I'll help
I'll be paying in i but obviously
Bobby's really good at planning stuff
that's a good sport a bobby like how can
I support you like let me know the Ben
no code like I will I will totally I
caught you on this or like I could you
like a hotel's reservation just give me
like a chunk of that Bobby